I've been covering how right wing media has
been covering the Biden administration for
several months now.
And the bottom line is that they do not know
what the hell to do with themselves.
The Joe Biden administration so far has been
completely absent of scandals.
They've made some progress in some areas.
They've turned around some of the disasters
left behind by the Donald Trump administration.
For example, vaccination has accelerated dramatically.
The economy continues to recover.
Jobs are recovering.
Stock market is at a record high.
Joe Biden passed a coronavirus stimulus.
He's now pushing infrastructure reform.
He's doing guns.
He's doing a lot of different things.
So right wing media has had to come up with
scandals, but they're really boring and they're
sort of what I would call fake scandals.
One is the focus on why Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris won't go to the border.
And, of course, you know, they have advisors.
They don't need to go to the border to understand
what's going on at.
The border, but that's one fake scandal that
the right has been pushing, they've done the
cancel culture stuff, focusing occasionally
and intermittently on Dr. Seuss or Major League
Baseball or whatever the case may be.
They try gotcha questions at press briefings
with Joe Biden's press secretary, Jen Psaki,
or sometimes with Joe Biden himself.
And the gotcha questions fail day after day
after day in a humiliating way.
Here is the latest fake scandal I present
to you now, an entire Newsmax segment devoted
to how Kamala Harris laughs and when she laughs,
I'm not kidding.
Here is a segment very concerned about Carmella's
laugh and drawing a parallel to the Wicked
Witch of the West, I guess, from the Wizard
of Oz.
Take a look.
So it got me thinking about Carmella's.
Cackling All right.
She is probably going to be president sooner
rather than later.
All right.
She's supposed to be the leader all women
should look up to.
But all I can actually remember her doing
since taking office is cackling at the most
strange moments to watch,
you know,
and not everybody landing punches like you
did, though.
So you don't mean it.
Oh, it's not even funny.
So I was racking my brain watching those clips
right there, trying to figure out.
Who in the heck does this woman remind me
of and then I realized she's from out west
and it
hit me.
We get the than.
Oh, boy, that's her that's cackling Comeaux,
the Wicked Witch of the West, Nancy Pelosi,
move over.
There's a new witch in town and her name,
of course, is cackling Komala.
Oh, how sad is that?
She is going to be president, by the way.
I don't think Joe Biden's going to be in here
for much longer.
We'll see.
Right.
I don't wish any harm to him at all, but we
shall see.
Guys, Comilla is laughing the wrong way and
at the wrong time.
This is an explosive issue.
Now, if you thought, first of all, how many
segments has Newsmax done about how male politicians
laugh?
You're asking an interesting question.
And as far as I know, the answer is zero.
Secondly, is there some sense in which this
is refreshing?
Because we know that these aren't real scandals?
What I mean by that is Trump failing on coronavirus
and the number of deaths that that caused
Trump regularly making the US a global laughing
stock, Trump launching a misguided trade war,
Trump crushing farmers with his policies.
You know, all of these real issues.
Now, the scandal is how Kamala Harris laughs
and whether Major League Baseball should be
boycotted.
Is there some sense in which it's refreshing
that these aren't real embarrassing scandals
at a global level?
I don't know.
But in all seriousness, they have no idea
what to do with themselves, and it's getting
very embarrassing.
I would expect more of this now.
At some point, there may be a real Biden administration
scandal.
Many administrations have scandals like, for
example, when Barack Obama was written suit
that rocked the world.
So at some point there may be a real scandal
and it could very quickly become a sort of
boy who cried wolf type of situation.
But Comilla laughing Guys, come on, you're
embarrassing yourselves.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We're going to take some of your calls.
I'm going to answer many of your questions.
We have a great program for you today.
Stay with us.
Back right after this.